ก็สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ส่วนคำนักเรียน
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนเย้เยนักเรียนทุกๆคน
ทุกคนเลยกลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับพี่ตีกับ
น้องเตรียมแย่ในช่องอะไร
เข้าไทยเย้เอ้าวันนี้ครับวันนี้เรา
มาเรียนภาษาไทยการวานนี้วันอะไรครับวัน
นี้วันพฤหัสบดีอ้าวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวัน
พฤหัสบดีที่เท่าไหร่ครับที่ 13 ค่ะวัน
พฤหัสที่ 13 โอเควันนี้วันพฤหัสที่ 13
แล้วเดือนเดือนนี้เดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้
เดือนมกราคมค่ะเดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมปี 2462
อะไรครับข้อ
2022  5  2022
โอเคครับแล้วปีพ.ศ I ครับพ.ศ
2565  5
2565 โอเคปีนี้ปีคศ 2010  22
ปีนี้ 2,000
22 ใช่ไหมครับนี้ปีนี้ 2,000  22a แล้ว
ปีที่แล้วอ่ะครับปีที่แล้ว
ปีที่เท่าไหร่ครับปีที่แล้วปี
2021  5 ปีที่แล้ว 2,000  21 นะครับหา
แล้วโอเคแล้วปีหน้านะครับปีหน้าปีหน้าปี
หน้าปี
2523 ค่ะปีหน้าปี 2010  23 โอเคกลับมา
กลับมาแต่ปีนี้ปีนี้ของพันธุ์
22 นะครับอ่าโอเคแล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้กี่โมง
แล้วครับตอนนี้
6 โมง 5 นาทีค่ะ
06:05 โอเค
18:00 น
5 นาทีโอเคต้องเย็นหรือตอนเช้าครับตอน
เย็นค่ะตอนเย็นนั่งอ๋อตอนนี้เป็นตอนเย็น
ใช่ไหมอ๋อโอเค
18:05 นตอนเย็นตอนเย็นไอ้ตอนนี้ 6 โมงย6
โมงก็ต้องถึงเวลากินข้าวแล้วสิครับน้อง
เรียนม
6 โมงแล้วหิวข้าวหิวข้าว
ข้าวเย็นใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะคนไทยเรียกว่าช่วง
เย็นเพราะว่าเป็นตอนเย็น
ใช่หรอข้าวแล้วอยู่ข้าวแล้วจ๊ะพี่ก็หิว
นิดหน่อยหิวนิดหน่อยอ่ะแต่น้องเรียมหิว
หิวมากใช่ไหมหิวมากๆ
ว่ามากเลย 5 ที่จะเอาอะไรมาให้เหลี่ยมดู
ค่ะเดี๋ยวพี่เอที่จะพาไปกินหาไปกินขนมขนม
ยิ้ม
ขนมจีนให้นักเรียนนักเรียนเคยเคยเคยกิน
ขนมจีนไหมครับน้า
ขนมจีนเคหะไปดูเป็นยังไงครับหน้าขนมจีน
เป็นแบบนี้ครับนี่นี่
ขนมจีนขนมจีนเป็นสีขาวแบบนี้น่าเป็นเส้น
ให้ครับเป็นเส้น CN เส้นเสื้อของเรียน
หน่อยอ่ะใช่ครับเสื้อเสื้อผ้าสีขาวหน้า
ขนมจีนก็สีขาว
ได้ครับขนมจีน R เป็นเส้นขนมจีนเวลากิน
ขนมจีนเรากินขนมจีนกับผัก
น่ากินกับผักได้ครับมีผัดหลายอย่างที่กิน
กับขนมจีนใช้ค่าหลายๆอย่างๆนี่ผัดหลาย
อย่างเลยมีนี่พักเยอะเยอะแยะเวลากิน
ขนมจีนไหมครับหน้ามีขนมจีนนะครับมีผากไหม
ครับแล้วก็มีแล้วก็มีน้ำอย่าเนี่ยน้ำยา
ขนมจีนที่กินด้วยกันนี่นี่เป็นขนมทีหน้า
นี้เป็นผักนี้เป็นน้ำยา
ทำอยากขนาดจีนเตรียมเห็นมีลูกชิ้น
ไส้ครับมีอ่าหินอยู่ตรงนี้หิว
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ชิ้นลูกชิ้นนั่นนี้ลูกชิ้นที่ใส่ในขนมจีน
เขาจะเป็นลูกชิ้นที่ทำมาจากทำมาจากปลา
น้าๆเป็นลูกชิ้นปลานะครับหน้าเหมือนปลา
ไหม
เป็นลูกชิ้นปลาเรลูกชิ้นปลาใส่ลงไปใน
ขนมจีน
หึ
ไข่เห็นอ้าใช่ครับนี่มีไข่อยู่ตรงนี้ไข่
ต้ม
นาคไข่ต้มนะครับไข่ต้มใส่ขนมจีนหม้อมี
พริกด้วยสำหรับคนที่ชอบชอบชอบกินเผ็ดกิน
เผ็ดชอบกินเผ็ดก็ใส่พริกเพิ่มและก็จำได้
ความแต่ว่าเป็นพริกแห้งใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ
เป็นผมแห้งนะครับนาปิดแห้งนั้นก็จะเผ็ด
เหมือนกันผิดแห้งก็เผ็ดในครับเธอน้อง
เรียมคอบกินเผ็ดไหมครับ
ชอบค่ะอ๋อชอบกินเห็ดหน้าเพียงตีก็ชอบกิน
เผ็ดเหมือนกันนะอ่าแล้วนักเรียนแล้วครับ
เดี๋ยวปิดกั้นนักเรียน Top ขอกินเผ็ดไม่
เอาชอบหรือไม่ชอบ
ใช่ครับคอมเม้นท์บอก
หรือว่าฉันจะกินไม่ได้ฮ่าๆๆอะๆคนไทยคนไทย
ชอบกินเผ็ดใช่ครับ
โอเคมีขนมจีนน้ำยาแล้วก็ลูกชิ้นนะครับนะ
เวลากินก็กินกับผักใช่ไหมกินกับผักก็ได้
เดี๋ยวพี่ตัดที่จะพาไปรู้มีขนมจีนที่กิน
กับ
นี้ไม่ได้กินกับน้ำยาขนมจีนกินกับแกงนี่
เป็นแกงเออแกล้งอะไรครับมีแกงอะไร
เรียงคิดว่าแกง
แกง
แจ้งใส่และ
ให้มันผมจีนแกงไก่โอเค
ใช่ครับขนมจีนแกงไก่นะก็
สามารถกินได้ข้างใส่ไก่ที่นี่ๆกับได้ใส่
ไก่ลงไปในแกงนะครับแล้วก็เอามากินกับ
ขนมจีนอ่า 5 เวลาที่คนไทยกินขนมจีนแกงไก่
ไม่ต้องกินผักไม่ได้กินกับผักอ้า
ๆเพราะอยู่ในแกงไก่ไม่แกงไก่มีผักอยู่
แล้วนี่มีผักอยู่ในแกงไก่หน้ามีมะเขือ
แล้วก็มีผักนับหน้าแต่ถ้าถ้ากินขนมจีน
ขนมจีนน้ำยาขนมจีนน้ำยาจะกินกับผัดนี้จะ
มีผักจะมีผัดน่าจะมีผักเยอะๆแบบนี้ชาย
ครับ
เตรียมก็หยิบผักหยิบผักหยิบผักมาใส่อ่ะ
เยอะๆ
ได้ได้ครับได้ครับ
เราก็อ้าอันนี้อะขนมจีนน้ำยาน้ำยา
ขนมจีนแกงไก่น่าอาคนภาคต่างจะกินขนมจีน
แกงไก่ขนมจีนน้ำยามีน้ำยามีน้ำยาที่กิน
กับขนมจีนของคนภาคอีสานผม
น้านี่ครับไหมคะ 5 ภาคอีสานจะอยู่ตรงนี้
นี่ภาพอีสานหน้างานมีเป็นภาคเหนือนิภาค
กลางนิภาคใต้นะครับน่ะถ้าเป็นเข็มทิศเป็น
วันนี้เป็น
เหนือ
ใต้ใช่ไหมตะวันออกอันนี้เป็นตะวันตกอีสาน
อยู่ตรงนี้
มีเงินไปอีสานคือภาคนี้นี่
มีภาคอีสานอยู่ตรงไหนอ่าฮะอีสานกินขนมจีน
เหมือนกันนะถ้าอีสานมีเอ่อน้ำยาที่ไม่
เหมือนไม่เหมือนกับน้ำยาขนมจีนของภาคกลาง
ไม่เหมือนนะอ่าหน้าตาของขนมจีนน้ำยา
ขนมจีนของภาคอีสานเป็นแบบนี้ครับนี้
จะมี
น้องเรียมน้องเรียมอยู่ภาคอีสานใช่ไหม
น้องเรียนอยู่ภาคอีสานด้วยครับอ่ะรู้จัก
นะจานนี้ไหมรู้จัก
เรียกเรียกน้ำยาอะไรครับเรียกว่าน้ำยาป่า
อ๋อเรียกน้ำยาป่า 5 น้ำยาปากเฮียตีก็ชอบ
ชอบกินน้ำยาป่า
นักเก็ตตี้ก็หยิบผักหยิบผังหาชายไม่ได้
เยอะๆๆครับใส่ผักเยอะๆอร่อยเพราะว่าเจ้า
ป่าเก็บเห็ด
มีเหตุต้องกินขัดมีผักเยอะๆเอาหน้านิ่ม
ผัดก็จะเผ็ดน้อยลง
หน้าขนมจีนน้ำยาป่าก็จะมีลูกชิ้นเหมือน
กันมีครับมีลูกชิ้นเป็นลูกชิ้นปลาใช่ไหม
เนื้อหาใช่ครับเป็นลูกชิ้นปลาเหมือนกัน
ลูกชิ้นปลาแล้วก็ห้าต่อน้ำยาป่าทั้งภาค
อีสานจะใส่จะสระเห็นน้ำปลาร้าด้วยไอ้น้ำ
ปลาร้าด้วยใช่ไหมจ้าๆอ่าใส่ปลาร้า
ส้มตำก็ใส่น้ำปลาร้าได้อ้ะส้มตำก็ใส่ปลา
ร้าในน้ำยาป่าก็หายน้ำปลาร้าใต้ครับหน้า
ใต้น้องเรียมกินกินปลาร้าได้ไหมเรียงกิน
ปลาร้าได้ค่ะขอกินได้ด้วยพี่ HD ก็กินได้
อ้าโอเคบางคนก็บอกว่า
น้ำปลาร้ากลิ่นเหม็นอ๋อใช่บางคนไม่ชอบไม่
ชอบกินปลาร้าหน้าหือแต่งหน้าแบบพี่
เอ็ดดี้ All
Clear ที่คิดว่าน้ำปลาร้ากลิ่นหอมไหมค่ะ
กลิ่นหอมครับน้ำปลาร้าหอมเครียดที่กินนะ
ใช่กินได้ใช่เขาถ้าคนที่ไม่กินคนที่ไม่
กินก็จะคิดว่าน้ำปลาร้าเหม็น
ทรายฮะ
โอเคอันนี้เป็นขนมจีนของภาคอีสานใช่ไหมมี
น้ำยาขนมจีนของภาคห้าไปภาคไหนดีไปภาคไหน
ดีอยากเห็นของภาคไหนอ๋อพันเหนือใช่ไหมภาค
เหนือก็มีขนมจีนเหมือนกัน 555 แต่ภาค
เหนือเป็นขนมจีนน้ำน้ำอะไรครับนี้พี่เปิด
ที่ดูรูปก่อนนี้น้ำเงี้ยวเข้าใจครับ
ขนมจีนน้ำเงี้ยวของภาคเหนือมี
แต่ของพรรคเหนือขนมจีนไม่เผ็ดไม่เผ็ดๆก็
จะมีรสหวานนิดหน่อยๆไม่เผ็ดเผ็ดนิดหน่อย
ใช่ครับมีรสหวานนิสัยอ่าอันนี้เป็นดอก
เงี้ยวใช่ครับเป็นหาดอกไม้ชนิดนึงดอกไม้
ชนิดหนึ่งชื่อว่าต้นเงี้ยวแล้วมีดอกก็เอา
ดอกไม้มาใส่ในขนมจีนใส่ในน้ำยาน้ำขนมจีน
จะเป็นดอกไม้อันนี้คือดอกไม้ใช่ไหมคะเป็น
ดอกไม้
ฮ้อนดอกเงี้ยวก็เป็นดอกไม้ใต้ครับ
แล้วก็สำหรับคนที่ชอบกินเผ็ดก็สามารถใส่
พริกลงไปได้ใส่พริกลงไปในขนมจีนได้เพื่อ
เพิ่มรสชาติน่าใส่พริกแห้ง
เริ่มหิวหรือยังครับก็เริ่ม
หิวมากๆค่ะพี่อิ๋วมากๆแล้วใช่ไหมครับโอเค
ๆเดี๋ยวเปียติ๊กพาไปพาไปอีกที่ประเทศไทย
ยังมีฉันสนธิเณรอยู่ดีภาคใต้ด้วยขนมจีน
ของภาคใต้ก็ไม่เหมือนไม่เหมือนน้ำยา
ขนมจีนของภาคเหนือไม่เหมือนไม่เหมือนกะ
หนมจีนของภาคกลางไม่เหมือนของภาคอีสานก็
ไม่เหมือนไปดูของผัดตายกันได้ครับไม่
เหมือนกันไม่เหมือน
อัดตายคันอ่าขนมจริงของภาคใต้จะเป็นน้ำยา
เหมือนกันนะครับในจะเป็นน้ำยาแบบนี้น้ำยา
จะมีสีเหลือง
อ่าเป็นน้ำยาที่ใส่ R ใส่สมุนไพรลงไปหน้า
สมุนไพรชื่อว่าเออสมุนไพรใส่ขมิ้นลงไป Mod
ใส่
ไอ้ขมิ้นก็จะมีสีเหลือดูหนังสีเหลืองแบบ
นี้
ก็น้ำยาของภาคใต้ก็จะมีรสเผ็ดรสเผ็ดหน้า
เพจแล้วก็เค็มใช่ครับเหตุและเค็มเนื้อ
เวลากินก็ต้องกินกับผักกินผักเยอะๆน่าใช้
งับ
20 ทรายผักกินผักใส่เยอะๆไปผัดเยอะมาก
เลยใส่ผักเยอะมากนะครับตัดแบบนี้เลยแบบ
นี้เลยอะเวลาไปร้านขนมจีนมีนักเรียนนัก
เรียนเคยเคยมาประเทศไทยแล้วไปที่สวน
จตุจักรไหมครับ
สวนจตุจักร 5 โรงเรียนรู้จักสวนจตุจักร
ไหมอ๋อรู้จักค่ะที่เรียกสวนจตุจักรหรือ
ว่า
ตลาดเจเจตลาดอ่ะทางการ JJ ใช่ไหมครับมี
ร้านขนมจีนแบบนี้อ้าใช่ครับ JJ  Market
มีขนมจีนแบบนี้ร้านนี้อยู่ที่สวนจตุจักร
เออนักเรียนเคยมาที่ส่วนจึงตัดจะเห็นร้าน
ขนมจีนแบบนี้เห็นน่าจะเห็นร้านขนมจีนแบบ
นี้ที่สวนจตุจักร
เตรียมคิดว่าเป็นร้านขายขายผัก
ให้ขายไม่ใช่ขายขนมจีนขายขนมขายจีนอิ่ม
กับผักอ่ะก็เลยมีผักเยอะผักเยอะมากนะครับ
เราหยิบผักใส่หยิบผักใส่ได้ฟรีใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ครับหยิบผักใส่ฟรี ER ค่ะคิกๆเยอะเลย
กินจนอิ่มเลยกินขนมจีนจานเดียว
แล้วเราหยิบผักกลับผู้ใหญ่บ้านได้ไหมคะ
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ต้องกินที่ร้านกิมที่นี่ห้าม
เอากลับบ้านกลับบ้านไม่ได้ออกกลับมาบ้าน
กลับมาไม่ได้อ๋อๆครับ
เวลาที่เอ่อมากินขนมจีนในประเทศไทยเรา
สามารถกินขนมจีนได้นะครับเวลาที่เรากิน
ขนมจริงก็จะมีที่จะไปกินก็คืออาจเป็นที่
ร้านแบบนี้นี่ไปนั่งกินที่ร้านร้านขนมจีน
แบบนี้นั้นก็ไป 3 ลาไปนั่งเพราะอ่าใช่
ครับแล้วก็สั่งขนมจีนได้นะครับหรือหรือ
ถ้าเราไม่ไม่ไม่ชอบไปกินที่ร้านเราก็
สามารถไปนั่งกินพี่ร้านข้างทางได้นะครับ
น่าจะมีเยอะขนมจีบขายดิร้านข้างทางนี่แบบ
นี้ตรงนี้ก็จะเป็นถนน
ณตอนนี้เป็นถนนโรมีรถวิ่ง
เลียรถวิ่งอยู่ครับใช่ห่ามีรถวิ่งอยู่
แล้วเราก็นั่งกินนะต้องกินข้างต่างกิน
ขนมจีนนะจ้าอยากนี้เป็นร้านข้างทางร้าน
ข้างทางราคาก็จะถูกกว่าถูกกว่านิดหน่อย
เออถูกกว่านิดหน่อยเออที่ร้านข้างทาง
แต่ถ้าไปที่อ่างจังหวัด
ต่างจังหวัดน่ะต่างจังหวัดก็คืออยู่เห็น
อ้ะพี่อาร์ตี้เปิดรูปแผนที่ประเทศไทยเทพ
หาได้ครับไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯแล้วอาจจะอยู่ที่
ต่างจังหวัดอาจจะอยู่นี่ต่างจังหวัดต่าง
จังหวัด
เนื้อที่ไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯอ่าก็จะมีขนมจีน
แบบนี้นักเรียนอาจจะเคยเห็นนะครับร้าน
ขนมจีนที่เป็นแบบนี้นี้โอ้นี่แบบนี้ไม่มี
ร้านไม่มีร้านไม่มีโต๊ะไม่มีชกใช่ครับ
เวลากินเราต้องถือถือถ้วยกินได้ครับแล้ว
ก็กินทีกินหน้าได้ก็มีผักให้เหมือนเดิม
ขนมจีนกินกับผักแล้วก็กินกับน้ำยานะครับ
น้าจะได้กลับก็นั่งกินนั่งกินบนตรงนี้
นั่งกินบนมานั่งตรงนี้เบี้ยตรงนี้
ชาย
ถ้า
ว้าวหิวหิวแล้วใช่ไหมหิวมากเลยตอนนี้มาก
โอเคแล้วนี้ก็คือวันนี้นะครับเราเรียน
เอ่อรู้เกี่ยวกับขนมจีนจะมีน้ำยาอะไรบ้าง
ครับวันนี้ที่เราเรียนกันเดี๋ยวนะอ่ากลับ
ไปดูมีน้ำยาอะไรบ้างอ่ามีอันนี้เรียกอะไร
ครับให้ดูนะคะขนมจีนอ่ะแปลจีนโอเคนกเส้น
ขนมจีนขอเรียกว่าเส้นขนมจีนชนะ
โอเคแค่มีขนมจีนกินกับอะไรครับกินกับขับ
หาดงาแสงครับกินกับผักแล้วก็มีน้ำยาใช่
ไหมเพลงน้ำยาและก็มีเมียอีกครับมีแกงไก่
ใช่ไหมอ่านี่ขนมจีนแกงไก่โอเคแล้วก็มีน้ำ
ยาอะไรอีกครับที่เป็นน้ำยาของการประสาน
ครับป่านี่ 5 น้ำยาป่านะครับ 5 แล้วถ้าไป
ภาคเหนือไปภาคเหนือมีมีขนมจีนหน่อยครับ
ขนมจีนน้ำเงี้ยวน้ำเหมียวนะอ่าใช่ครับ
หน้าแล้วก็มีน้ำยาของภาคใต้ไหว้ตายายอาบ
น้ำยาของภาคใต้ขอแค่ครับสำหรับวันนี้น่า
จะหิวมากเลยนะ
เมื่อ
คืนเสีย New ไหมอ่ะครัวตี้เปิดที่อ้าว
เริ่มหิวมากขึ้นมานิดนึงฮ่าๆๆโอเค
เดี๋ยวเราเดี๋ยวเราพักไปกินข้าวก่อนไปกิน
ข้าวก่อนแล้วเดี๋ยวเรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่ใน
คลิปหน้านะครับใช่ครับสอบวันนี้ปาร์ตี้
ลาวพยายามต้องลาไปก่อนครับหน้าสวัสดีครับ
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนที่มบ๊ายบายเรียนม